t-minus three two one explosion please
[Music]
you see a military contractor destroying
100 tons of weapons in Iraq but our
experts see a shining beacon of
super-sized carnage first thing you see
is the light that's formed from the
explosion the second thing is that you
notice the tripod of the camera shakes
and this is because shock wave from the
explosion has traveled through the
ground and is now shaking the tripod
legs and the third thing is that we hear
the explosion we hear the sound as a
clear illustration of the difference
between the speed of light and the speed
of sound
very interesting but what in the name of
science is that do you see what looks
like some sort of a halo effect and what
this is due to is the expanding gases of
the explosion rush out rapidly and they
displace the normal air around them and
you have a region of low pressure and
surrounding this is all of the
compressed air of very high pressure and
then surrounding that you have your
normal air so is this area of low
pressure air increases it gets colder
and cold air makes clouds for a fraction
of a second you're actually looking at a
cloud of water vapor there's some
incredible physics going on here so
congratulations to these kings of
carnage for proving that the bigger the
bang
the bigger the science
[Music]